bonjour xavier richet merci de répondre
à nos questions sur rt france pourquoi
la france fait-elle plus de tolérance
fait-elle preuve de plus de tolérance à
l'égard de why why par rapport aux états
unis ou au royaume uni bonjour alain
d'abord majeau ptre ce fait un principe
disons de réalité c'est à dire que la
france avec d'autres pays européens
fortement engagés dans des relations
économiques avec la chine donc lhi un
problème est ce que c'est ce sont des
échanges qui sont ouverts ou est ce que
disent on segmente et donc la france a
choisi de contribuer à l'équipement avec
la technique singer en ouvrant les
opérateurs aux deux opérateurs chinois
en france mais avec des conditions que
vous avez rappelé c'est à dire la
définition de sites sensibles sur
lesquels l'opérateur chinois ne
pourraient pas rentrer donc c'est un
principe de réalité je pense que
d'autres pays peut-être bon suis je
pense à l'allemagne en particulier qui
est un des principaux investisseurs même
le principal investisseur européen en
chine
justement vous venez de parler des
interdictions sont des sites sensibles
pour moi ouais ça veut dire quoi sites
sensibles dire que bon la technologie
pour je sais pas ouvrir sa cafetière
chocolat que contrôler le trafic des
routes mais aussi ça peut avoir des
implications sur les systèmes de défense
des systèmes disons le docteur de deux
systèmes très important et qu'il est
nécessaire de protéger donc ça c'est une
chose tout à fait normal que les hôtels
et les gouvernements français sécurisé
le nom des secteurs sur des sources
d'informations militaires ou
technologique ce terrain donc ça c'est
un premier principe mais sur le reste
disons l'opérateur chinois pourra opérer
normalement vous l'avez dit donc
autoriser weiwei en france est crucial
pour l'économie française est ce que ça
veut dire que c'est un jeu
d'équilibriste pour paris vous avez
évoqué berlin également c'est un jeu
d'équilibriste parce que l'europe est
pris en tenaille entre les états unis
d'un côté et la chine de l'autre au
niveau des relations de lundi qu'est ce
qui va se passer
oui alors je crois qu'il faut il faut
voir un peu ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
entre les etats-unis et la chine il ya
une espèce de sinnoh phobie qui se
développe on est proche de l'année
prochaine élection aux états unis les
etats-unis ont qu à un retard
technologique dans ce domaine et
n'accepte pas bon d'être concurrencé par
d'autres pays notamment des pays
émergents
il ya donc ce cette attitude alors je
pense pas que l'europe soit prise en
tenaille l'europe a des possibilités bon
je pense que au niveau l'europe
il ya toute une réflexion aujourd'hui
pour comment investir dans ces
technologies comment créer contribué à
créer des champions nationaux
donc je pense que disons par rapport à
l'autorisation est donnée aux opérateurs
chinois de repérer chez nous il y a
toujours une recherche hisse au fait il
ya toujours des goûts qui peuvent
accroître leurs innovations et et
croître et je pense que ça c'est une
dimension européenne on parlait tout à
l'heure des succès récents le dit hier
au niveau européen autres en chef à être
au niveau d'innovation comment disons au
niveau européen pensé à créer et à
faciliter l'émergence de ses champions
nationaux
ça c'est un pan des pans deuxième point
c'est la possibilité pour les chiens
européennes y compris dans le secteur
des hautes technologies d'entrer sur le
marché chinois donc pied protéger encore
est notre cas des négociations entre
l'europe et la chine
ou disons qu'ils tournent autour des
diplômes à dire programme
d'investissement cadres etc
c'est un enjeu important que les
européens doivent mettre en avant c'est
à dire la réciprocité c'est pas
uniquement d'avoir des produits chinois
ou des techniciens finissaient tous il a
profité d'entrées sur le secteur protégé
en chine et diplomatiquement
quelles conséquences à presser
décision de paris quelles conséquences
vis-à-vis de ses alliés occidentaux
quelles conséquences vis-à-vis de la
chine vis-à-vis le bon je crois que il
faut sortir un peu de gym sorte de
paranoïa aujourd'hui à qui s'instaure au
niveau international autour de la chine
le pays et monique fait un tendance
hégémonique et cetera il faut
relativiser bondé dénommé dans
lesquelles la chine tout à fait
dépendantes reste très dépendant
d'autres bouts à la d1 boursiers et je
crois qu'il faut seriez un peu les
problèmes et non pas avoir une attitude
disons frontale si vous regardez ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans le retour de
la chine
il peut très bien y avoir comme on dit
dédé des conflits il peut très bien y
avoir un dérapage qui te conduire
peut-être pas des solutions extrêmes
mais il faut bien voir l'état dans
lequel on trouve donc je pense
personnellement je pense que c'est
important de dédramatiser et disons de
discuter beaucoup plus sérieusement de
dison de penser des réciprocités des
titres 4 comme on dit en anglais on
s'attire des mesures de rétorsion quand
quelqu'un pour un api prend une décision
pas répondre vers lons ceci dit il reste
important de mettre les points sur les i
et ii dire les points sur lequel on est
en total désaccord avec les chinois je
pense en particulier sur les problèmes
des droits de l'homme s'ils se passe
aujourd'hui de chez les ouïghours au
xinjiang ce qui se passe à hong kong
c'est un être absolument ferme l'europe
doit montrer sa fermeté vis-à-vis ces
questions mais ça n'empêche pas de
discuter sur le plan commercial sur le
plan industriel les coopérations
possibles et souhaitables avec la chine
merci xavier richaud d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur d'économie spécialiste de la
chine